- [murmuring indistinctly]
[baby cooing]
- HEY, WATCH WHERE THE [bleep]
YOU GOING.
- OH, MY GOSH,
I'M SO SORRY.
- OH.
[baby giggles]
I DIDN'T SEE YOU HAD
A BABY THERE, MAN.
I'M SORRY. I AIN'T TRYING
TO FIGHT NOBODY WITH A BABY.
[baby gurgles]
- YEAH, H-HELL YEAH,
YOU WON'T.
- PFFT.
- [clears throat]
- LUCKY MOTHER[bleep].
- OH, YEAH?
WELL, YOU'RE LUCKY
I'M CARRYING THIS BABY.
WHAT'S UP WITH THAT?
- LOOK, MAN, YOU NEED
TO MOVE ON, ALL RIGHT?
I ALREADY TOLD YOU
I'M NOT GONNA FIGHT YOU.
- HUH.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT, PUNK.
- PSH.
- YOU WANNA GO?
'CAUSE WE CAN GO
RIGHT NOW, DOG.
WHAT'S GOIN' ON, BROTHER?
- MAN, WHAT THE HELL
ARE YOU DOING, MAN?
- WHAT, WHAT, WHAT?
YOU TR--WHAT, WHAT?
TRYIN' TO BO--
I CAN BOB AND WEAVE IT.
- WHAT?
- YOU BITCH-ASS,
PUNK-ASS MOTHER[bleep],
LET'S GO.
COME ON, MAN.
COME ON.
NO, NO, DON'T LOOK AT YOUR BOYS.
LOOK AT ME, MAN.
[high-pitched voice]
DON'T LOOK AT YOUR B--
OW.
OH, OKAY,
YOU THINK YOU HARD.
ALL RIGHT,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'MA SHOW YOU WHAT TIME IT IS
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY? SLAP ME.
I'M JUST--RIGHT?
HOW 'BOUT THIS, HUH?
NOW WHAT YOU GONNA DO, HUH?
NOW WHAT YOU GONNA DO?
YOU READY?
'CAUSE WE CAN DO IT RIGHT NOW.
'CAUSE I COULD TAKE YOU OUT,
MAN.
YOU'RE NOTHING--
[whack]
OW!
OH! OOF.
[wincing]
OKAY.
OH, IT'S ON NOW.
THAT'S--YEP.
YOU DEAD.
[dramatic action music]
EXCUSE ME, I NEED THIS.
YEAH.
♪ ♪
NECESITO UN BEBE.
- [gasps]
- GRACIAS.
♪ ♪
LISTEN.
[babies crying]
- WHAT THE--
- WHAT NOW, MAN?
WHAT NOW?
LET'S GO.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S NOT EVEN WORTH IT, MAN.
- AHH, HA HA.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT!
SO KEEP WALKING!
OH. OKAY, THAT'S VOMIT.
THAT IS VOMIT.
[baby burps]
OH, DEAR.